feels like now we're in this
third stage where there's
uh chrome firefox
edge i guess it's called and
brave and these are all seem like really
exciting i don't know innovative
browsers they're all kind of copying off
of each other picking up the good stuff
there's evolution again especially on
tracking protection so privacy
is this sort of global um
wave that's rising i like to call it a
wave because it's a large
somewhat chaotic structure it's not a
unitary good you can't say
i'm buying privacy for you know three
dollars i'm paying three dollars privacy
some people think a vpn does this and
are disappointed when it fails them but
often people use vpns for
region unlocking video or getting the us
netflix exactly
um but privacy is is not a unitary good
it's complex and
people are understanding it only over
time and as they get burned but there's
a
genie that's not going back in the
bottle there people are fed up
apple has responded to this apple was
always making safari i think more
of a privacy branded browser from the
very beginning i think this is probably
steve jobs
safari had private windows private tabs
before
firefox did um and these are only
private in the sense that they don't
leave local
traces uh if you don't want them to
turns out safari does keep them around
between shut down but the canonical
model is no local traces after you close
the private window
no no leftover traces that you went to
you know some site that you were
embarrassed by or bought a gift for
somebody you wanted to keep secret
um but there's still some level of
tracking there's network
uh tracking there's network privacy is
not guaranteed at all because you're
using the same internet and isp
as a public window a non-private window
but sorry had that early on they also
had
a cookie blocking policy that um
might take a little explaining when you
if you know what a cookie is it's a
little bit of storage in the browser
indexed by the name of the site
and it's really only the main name of
the site like bfa.com
or um you know something like
npr.org um every site can store some
information a cookie
every time it's contacted by the browser
the previous version is sent back
and in the response from the server the
cookie's updated
so it's this little bit of storage in
the browser that the site can keep
updating and it can store an encrypted
version of your login credentials with a
timestamp so you can
stay logged in without having to re-type
your password every time you navigate
which is how it would be
if you didn't have cookies the web
protocols
uh especially in the 90s are so-called
stateless protocols so
you go to your bank you log in you go
from your login
confirmed page to your account view if
you didn't have a cookie you'd be
logging in again
everything every time you type in so so
that was a great thing about cookies
lumon totally did it in a hurry in 1994
before i joined that escape and he did
it for really
holding that kind of credential but
even then there was the image element
embedded in the page and the image gets
fetched
possibly from a different server and
that request carries the last
cookie which could be empty at first and
the response carries the updated cookie
so just by having images and cookies you
have tracking because that image server
can be
serving a little one by one pixel and
they still use the word pixel and ad
tech
and that pixel can be served from the
same server embedded differently with
different
url spellings in the new york times and
espn as you go from one to the other
the image server can say i haven't got a
cookie for you it's empty initially i'm
going to
assign you user number one two three
four i'm going to put a database entry
in
and i see by the way i always fetch the
name of the path part of the url that i
was in the new york times
so you're a new york times reader and
then you hit espn
same thing and the database gets updated
and the number user one two three four
indexes in the database
to a profile of you you've been tracked
this was not
intended and it was too late to undo by
the time i got the netscape
um i think lou wanted to do twinkies he
called them and
he was trying to solve several problems
he wanted them to be bigger because
initially cookies had a short size limit
i think he wanted to solve the third
party problem but tom pake when the
engineering manager said
nope no twinkies just cookies we're done
you're done son
and um that's how a lot of that stuff
was that's how javascript you know
um got frozen like a flying amber in
some ways with that sloppy equality
operator that i made because of the
early adopters
and the cookie got stuck with this
tracking hazard and then
because javascripts can be like images
they're embedded in the page
by the time in netscape 3 i made that
work you can get a request with the last
cookie value and the response updates it
that's a tracking mechanism and that's
why you don't even need images to track
now you just use scripts
so this whole tracking uh economy
evolved
and it it depended on these accidents of
the 90s these unintended consequences
well it created
some of the richest companies in the
world right i mean it's the social media
all i got was t-shirts
all i got is this crappy t-shirt yeah
i mean so that's that's the fundamental
problem the world is facing now they're
looking at what social media has created
and they're looking
at and like a world is looking at itself
in the mirror
and uh seeing that privacy is actually
something
as opposed to like a nice thing to have
it's something that is
actually should be fundamental to the
way we interact with the world
as part of our tooling and that's where
the brave browser comes in and i suppose
others as well are playing with this
idea but brave is at the forefront of
that so
maybe can you like describe what brave
is yes and what are its key principles
and uh what's broken and what is it
brave trying to fix so when i
realized that these accidents like the
third party cookie
the image or script that's tracking you
or the um
the javascripts that can do it invisibly
now that all this stuff wasn't
intended and that firefox had supported
extensions that blocked some of these
things i thought
probably we should have browsers just
block some of these things by default
these were not intended and they're now
unsafe they're tracking you there could
be data breaches
malware distribution um you know
bullying and psyops and other attacks on
people um
block that stuff block that javascript
i've i'm dr frankenstein i've gotta
deal with the monster here but obviously
you go to gmail there's a bunch of
script there to make that amazing web
client
that's okay that's first party
javascript so how do you tell the first
from the third party and it's not easy
it's not a matter of just
what's embedded from a different server
because a lot of
publishers use benign scripts from
unrelated domains or apparently
unrelated domains
so you end up having to develop a sort
of human and machine learning
practice around blocking and
at brave we did that from the start and
built a research team to help
drive it and automate it we realized
that protecting people
needed machine learning and around 2017
spring i talked to my friends
at apple about this too and they were
also doing what they call intelligent
tracking prevention
which uses local machine learning in the
browser and
the funny thing is we you know great
great mindset like we were they were
taking their third-party cookie blocker
that was in safari from the old days
and making it not have a big loophole
because what they did was in
2003 when sorry came out they said we're
going to block cookies that
are from those third-party embedded
elements
where you've never visited that site
before so i'm going to pick an
ad company that got sold to att so i'm
not picking on anybody unfairly
appnexus.com have you ever been to
appnexus.com no i've never been there
but i guarantee you 10 years ago you
probably had if you're using firefox you
had a cookie third-party cookie because
you're being
tracked by them and they were using that
cookie to build up a profile of you
in safari as long as the user never went
to app nexus
that cookie would not be set and that
was a real move for privacy early on
when jobs were still around in safari
but it had this loophole that if you do
go to app nexus then why it's okay to be
a third-party cookie and
so apnex just did something very naughty
they took their ad partners they put the
actual
ad you click on and they said hey add a
little script so that when somebody
clicks on the ad before it goes to your
landing page redirect to app nexus and
we'll redirect to the landing page
and by doing that they set a first party
cookie and they got whitelisted so as a
loophole they exploited
intelligent tracking prevention in
safari was sophisticated enough to to
counteract this and it did other things
and it's evolved since they didn't
and we've evolved brave too and so when
i say machine and human learning there's
a real
um set of techniques here they have to
fight fascinating problems
fingerprinting right anytime you have a
little bit of storage in the browser
associated with a website if the bad guy
can get 32 websites
each one has a bit of storage that's 32
bits you can
turn the bit on or off you can make 4
billion numbers you can make an
identifier it's called a
super cookie sometimes it's a
there are weaker ways that are
statistical they're called
fingerprinting you have to block all of
them and you have to not only automate
you want to work in the web standards
body to
put privacy in by default by design from
the get go not add it as an afterthought
or
you know go hog wild with new web apis
that add a bunch more
local storage or fingerprint surface
area
and that's been a struggle too because
guess who's the new microsoft in the
standards body it's google
and they're not in favor of privacy
first they
they want to do privacy their way only
under i would say market pressure
but with apple uh and with brave leading
the way we we block third-party cookies
almost without exceptions so
we've just blocked them and that gives
us a very strong privacy uh
benefit but it also means some sites
just don't work right embedded youtube
videos might not work right so we're
adapting in similar way to apple's done
with itp
to make third-party cookies blocked
but to sort of simulate
what looks like a working third-party
cookie for the site it
essentially tries to partition each site
and its third parties into its own
sort of cookie jar got it and so and
like like you said is
is this both like a human uh fine tuning
issue and a machine learning
problem so as the humans learn then they
train the machine learning but you know
uh maybe google side or including google
there's millions of dollars if not b
billions of dollars to be made
from fighting the ways of brave that's
right and it's been
uh an interesting change from when we
started in 2015 when we started
you know ad blocking extensions adblock
plus was one of the big ones that
started on firefox in 2006 i believe
had gotten to a certain level of use
around the world and browsers like uc
web uc browser in asia had some amount
of ad blocking built in
and on by default so a page fair was a
startup
and they measured ad blocking adoption
and they tried to say hey publishers
you're you know 30 of the visitors to
pitchfork or wire to condensed
properties or using ad blockers
if we can somehow convince them to lower
their ad blocking
for your site that could be like a 43
lift right
and three sevenths well that's easier
said than done and page fair and others
source point
many others tried to either smuggle ads
through or cajole the user into
letting you know ads appear and it
didn't really work and meanwhile the ad
blocking adoption is just continued
intelligent tracking prevention in
safari in 2017
brave from 2016 on with very strong
cookie blocking and other productions
and this this is not going away the
publishers used to rage against it like
we would try to say we can help you
you're dealing with users who are
already blocking all your ads
we can try to put back uh some economics
that help the user and you
that led to the basic attention token
that we started with bitcoin
we can be your friend don't don't just
fingerprint us as an ad blocker and
treat us as an enemy
but in 2015 or 16 it was like ah you're
an ad blocker get out of here i hate you
and by 2017 or 18 it's like something's
happening the app walking is not
stopping and
we're all getting sort of pulled onto
google's plantation
through amp amp or you know we're
getting killed by the google ad system
we use because it's taking all the
revenue
or you know it's permitting or some
other vendors we use are permitting ad
fraud and so
a fake new york times is getting paid by
the marketer running an ad
that a bot clicks on and the real new
york times
it's supposed to get that doesn't get it
and there's something really broken
about that kind of system
and that that fraud is mediated through
google's ad exchange which is the
biggest of them all
and google takes a fee there's a flip
side of that which is malware
distribution advertising where
fake advertisers put malware payloads in
or
exploit kit loaders in javascript and
they smuggle them in ads onto real
publisher
pages the ad exchange takes the fee now
i'm not a lawyer i'm not going to say
this is a ricoh predicate but
why is the ad exchange facilitating
fraud and malware distribution and
taking a fee it's not right
you